EU education ministers meeting in
Brussels stressed that investing in
quality education is key to relaunching
economic growth in Europe it should
therefore be seen as a priority of the
eu's 2020 strategy in these were
expected the council stressed that
mobilizing resources and to raise
Education and Training quality and
opportunities should be a priority for
our long-term and safe investment
ministers agreed also that Europe must
promote the development of
entrepreneurial skills through Education
and Training the aim is to move towards
a more business-like mindset which can
help create new jobs
another way to create job opportunities
is by improving Mobility hence the
importance for EU ministers to extend
the participation of students and young
Professionals in programs such as
Erasmus Plus
in the afternoon ministers focused on
youth issues and especially on how to
guarantee their access to education and
help them become independent and active
members of society